oh
no come on fall down fall down dude fall
down
wait who won
[Music]
no i thought the ball was gonna roll
down and hit
i probably overthought that no
yeah i'm not gonna win this one but
come on get up get up get up get up get
up get up
how does he go forward
you lose four games and we've been in
the finals every single time chat
every single time
yeah i like i don't have a good strat at
least for starting out
oh come on dude come on
oh i actually could have stretched that
out a little bit longer i think
if i had been ready oh dude look at that
little punk man look oh
no see we can just cut this guy off
right here
oh he came back dude
it's like nah i'm not allowing that i'm
cutting you off
oh no
and okay we're still in and i had 10 of
it eliminated
no no i screwed it up there was only one
left
you lose
oh oh that was nice
oh how did i miss
what is this guy doing
that was that was total stupidity by me
no all right it's changing hands a lot
over there
25 seconds man i don't like it
oh that cost me
[Music]
dude imagine if i grab you lose
see i can keep this for the whole entire
two minutes
i haven't lost it yet
oh here comes somebody ron dude run we
gotta protect the yellow ones
it's actually really close look at that
four five four three
green is in trouble right now
oh and there's a green guy coming
i can't see wait wait what
oh you like that
dude we just swiped it right out from
under him
oh whoever did this wow is that smart
out of my way don't grab me whoever was
just like
tossing him there what a brilliant idea
because look how many we've got just
just waiting here for us
all right back off blue
back off blue everybody's trying to
steal ours no no no no
all right we gotta go on the attack
red looks like the least defended right
now
yeah get out of here yellow
oh there's a gold one right there
really close by the way look at this
what are the physics on that one i feel
like my yellow team knows what's up
though these guys are being
ruthless right now yeah get that gold
one in there
get that going in there nicely done yeah
blue's the one in trouble right now
they got nobody back protecting look at
this
blue blue is kidding everybody's taking
blues right now
they're down to nine yellow team
in dominant form at the moment that's
what i like to see yellow
oh is red gonna hold them off yeah blue
is eliminated
all right we need to eliminate 16
players
look at this guys he moved i almost got
him off
i almost shoved him off
they've definitely changed this game
this is this one is a lot harder than it
was
because this one used to be really easy
for like the first minute
oh that one's gonna get some people no
it actually didn't
here's the fun part guys i would not
grab here guys it is risky you can hurt
yourself just as much as you can hurt
the other person
yeah see i'm just relaxing i'm just i'm
just going back and forth right here
just back and forth look at that only
eliminated five
wow oh this is it this is it
chat first crown coming up who's ready
who's ready for it i'm ready
oh
oh no come on fall down fall down dude
fall down
[Music]
wait who won did i get it yes let's go
first of all guys victory
[Music]
that other guy's gonna be so mad you win
perfect oh my goodness
[Applause]
[Music]